Hancock the former Health secretary is  to appear on I'm a celebrity which  begins filming in Australia this weekend  and airs on ITV from Sunday he of course  was held secretary during the pandemic  then had to resign over an affair with a  colleague and pictures of that during  the lockdown we've heard from a  political Ally of Matt Hancock about his  decision to appear on the show he told  us that it's the most watched show on  ITV and it's an incredible opportunity  for him to engage with 12 million  britons who tune in every night this  Ally went on Matt has always believed in  communicating directly with the people  he represents whether that's pounding  the streets in West Suffolk that's his  constituency where this Ally says that a  team will be supporting constituents who  need help with anything and they say  politicians like Matt must go where the  people are